à l'otan ils nous fascine qui nous
obsède on cherche à en gagner et on rage
nous en fait perdre
on prend le temps parfois même on
cherche à le tuer ou à le combattre
et depuis la nuit des temps l'humanité
cherche à comprendre comment il
fonctionne
alors le temps c'est aussi de l'argent
notre temps d'attention et une ressource
qui a énormément de valeur notamment
pour des sociétés comme facebook ou
google par exemple
alors je pense que vous êtes comme moi
nous ressentons son écoulement les
événements s'enchaînent les événements
nos vies s'enchaînent les uns après les
autres dans un sens et évidemment nous
revenons pas en arrière
nous allons vieillir
et cette notion de temps de temps qui
s'écoule et bien ça nous ramène à nos
propres angoisses
nous allons un jour ou l'autre
disparaître
alors avant toute chose j'aimerais un
petit peu vous présenter une une
citation qui m'inspire justement au
niveau du temps ir est derrière demain
et mystère est aujourd'hui est un cadeau
c'est pour cela qu'on l'appelle le
présent
m liu wei dans kung fu panda
alors chacun ses références évidemment
alors le temps c'est quoi le concept de
temps face
on peut essayer de le définir en se
basant sur notre quotidien ce notre
ressenti au quotidien si je vous demande
ce que c'est le temps vous avez sans
doute me dire que c'est une succession
d'événements je veux me souviens du
passé je vis le présent évidemment je
connais pas le futur
et ça na newton qu'il a conceptualisé
il a émis l'idée qu'on avait un temps
universel le temps peu importe ce qui se
passe peu importe les événements c'est
toujours le temps qui passe
on pourrait essayer de le visualiser par
exemple
en se demandant ce qui se passe
maintenant sur une autre planète au même
moment où je vous parle peut-être même
dans une autre galaxie il doit bien se
passer quelque chose en même temps
et tout ce que je viens de vous dire là
en fait c'est complètement faux le temps
le temps c'est pas ça du tout c'est une
vision complètement biaisé qu'on en a et
sans le sait depuis
einstein et sa théorie de la relativité
le temps est relatif c'est à dire qu'il
est influencé
il peut être étiré il peut être ralenti
c'est grâce à lui qu'on le sait
où d'ailleurs on peut le voir ici le
temps peut être modifié grâce à la masse
d'un objet ou alors la vitesse
alors
maintenant qu'on voit un petit peu ce
qui est le temps est ce que c'est que le
justement la théorie du temps c'est
intéressant quand même de se poser la
question
à quel moment les humains et l'humanité
a cherché à comprendre comment ça
fonctionnait et quels outils sont
utilisés justement pour le définir parce
que c'est grâce à des outils très
perfectionnés
on peut maintenant de savoir que le
temps est relatif
alors les premiers objets de mesure du
temps c'est très difficile de d'avoir un
consensus à ce sujet mais on pense que
c'est suite à l'observation des astres
et de notamment du cycle jour nuit que
les premiers on va plus à des chercheurs
se sont intéressés à essayer de mesurer
le temps notamment avec des calendriers
d'abord on a eu les calendriers mayas
grec égyptien est le premier outil
vraiment qu'on a trouvé c'est un cadran
solaire en 1500 avant avant jésus-christ
ya encore une fois y'a pas de
les experts se se battent encore pour
savoir si c'est vraiment le premier
outil mais on peut par tirer dessus quoi
qu'il arrive le cadran solaire a été
encore utilisé derrière par les grecs
jusqu'en 400 avant jésus-christ et ce
qui est surprenant et jeu peut-être
d'heure
on peut surprendre là dessus c'est que
pendant 2000 ans
ça va pas beaucoup évolué en fait
derrière on va avoir des objets comme
par exemple les sabliers qui vont être
utilisés pour mesurer des temps courts
mais la première révolution ça va se
passer plutôt au 14e siècle dont qui
s'est passé quand même un sacré laps de
temps justement et on va avoir des
horloges qui vont donner le leur mais
d'une façon un peu particulière c'est à
dire que ça va être des horloges de type
2 et de celle ci qui vont sonner en fait
on va pas avoir leur avec les aiguilles
comme qu'on a traditionnellement alors
ici on a un astrolabe donc on a des
choses un peu particulière sur la sur
les événements célestes mais c'est déjà
surprenant on est encore loin des
montres et des objets qu'on connaît qui
mesure le temps
il va encore se passer à peu près deux
cents ans où il va pas se passer grand
chose pour être honnête mais on va avoir
quelques horloger vraiment
vraiment drian comme christian huygens
qui va inventer un nouveau système qui
va améliorer justement la précision des
horloges parce que c'était vraiment le
but à l'époque c'était de pouvoir avoir
quelque chose de plus en plus précis et
de d'essayer de transporter le temps ce
que si vous voulez là à l'époque ce ce
type d'horloge à son énorme elles sont
dans les les églises elle gère le temps
religieux et donc là on à christian
huguet qui va inventer un système à
pendules à l'heure avant c'était des
systèmes hydrauliques et donc on va
avoir de grosses innovations à partir de
là avec deux le système de mécanismes de
ce type là
ce qui va se passer derrière c'est que
on va voir on va toujours essayer de
d'améliorer la précision des horloges et
de continuer à les rendre beaucoup plus
petit et beaucoup plus transportable
c'est vraiment ça qui va motiver les uns
les ingénieurs on peut dire ça à
l'époque et des horlogers évidemment
pour trouver les systèmes et réduire les
mouvements mécaniques donc on va arriver
très rapidement à des montres de ce type
là des montres à gousset donc pour
ensuite voilà on est déjà d'ailleurs ça
existe toujours
on en fait toujours de ce type là c'est
un petit peu moins branchés quand même
mais mais ça existe toujours et on va
avoir les montres bracelets
et donc voilà on arrive à peu près à
notre époque la dernière révolution
qu'on va avoir dans l'horlogerie ça va
être prince enfin les montres à quartz
je sais pas si ça vous parle ça va
vraiment mettre en péril l'horlogerie
traditionnelle bleu l'horlogerie que moi
je connais et que j'aime va être
vraiment mise en péril à cette époque là
puisqu'on va avoir des mouvements qui
vont être plus précis qui vont être
moins cher et ça va être une révolution
alors un mouvement à quartz est un
système c'est le cristal de quartz qu'on
mesure et qui on a trouvé qu'il était
très très précis non dans sa résonance
vous pouvez comme ça avoir des
mouvements qui est des rivets seulement
d'une seconde tous les 6 à 10 ans alors
qu'un mouvement traditionnel mécanique
comme dans une montre à gousset par
exemple va dériver en général de 15 20
30 secondes par jour s'il est mal réglé
donc donc après le
les horloges à quartz et les montres à
quartz on va voir aussi le système
d'horloges atomiques qu'on utilise
actuellement qui est encore plus précis
et qui la permet d'avoir une dérive
d'une seconde par million d'années je
pense qu'on est plutôt tranquille en
termes de précision dans l'horlogerie
alors ce qui manque ce qui m'intéresse
maintenant puisqu'on a fait un petit
point un peu sur le
l'histoire de l'horlogerie très
rapidement je vous le concède
on peut un petit peut se poser la
question de ce qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
mouvement mécanique est globalement les
mouvements mécaniques tous fonctionnent
de la même manière je sais que les
puristes vont me tomber dessus mais
vraiment que ce soit une rolex ou une de
mai montre ou tout autre monde mécanique
fonctionne de la même manière d'ailleurs
parlant de rolex je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez de de cette citation un
site a pas une rolex à 50 ans tu as raté
ta vie donc j'aimerais bien savoir
combien il ya de rater ce soir à un
relevé le bras oui moi aussi looser
hockey
non je plaisante ggp a 50 ans
alors comment fonctionne un mouvement
mécanique globalement il ya trois choses
à retenir on va avoir une force motrice
on va avoir la transmission et la
régulation
la c1 au mouvement qu'on utilise donc un
mouvement suisse on va voir on va
appliquer une force que ce soit sur la
couronne ou avec un une masse oscillante
qui va tourner automatiquement quand on
porte le mouvement quand on porte
malheur monde pardon qui va remonter ce
resort l'énergie dans le resort vouloir
ressortir et avait transmises aux
rouages qui eux mêmes vont transmettre
cette énergie
au balancier spiral le balancier spiral
c'est lui qui sert à réguler justement
le mouvement et des oscillations alors
sur un mouvement de bonne facture on va
avoir à peu près 28 800 alternances par
heure donc on parle vraiment de ce tic
tac et c'est de là que vient un petit
accès on à l'anc russie qui tape dans le
balancier spiral qui fait
un nouveau mystère de l'horlogerie
alors ce qui est intéressant aussi et
passionne dans leur logis c'est de
pouvoir
voir énormément de choses différentes
c'est difficile de vraiment
comment dire
d'écrire toutes les possibilités en
termes de complications horlogères on va
quand même constater qu'il ya
des grandes complications de ce type qui
vont être les calendriers on peut voir
des calendriers voilà il ya des choses
très très compliqué ne veux pas perdre
mon temps à me l'expliquer tellement c
c'est complexe bon là c'est des mondes
qui coûte 300 mille euros donc pas la
portée de tout le monde mais c'est quand
même beau à regarder on va avoir aussi
les montres de type
grande sonnerie alors ça c'est
intéressant puisque les grande sonnerie
il ya une petite anecdote à l'époque
c'est les nobles qui souhaitaient
avoir leur quand il était la nuit quand
il dormait et évidemment ils pouvaient
pas allumer la lampe à huile tout à
chaque fois et donc ce qui se passait
c'est qu'ils ont demandé aux horlogers
d'inventer un système est donc en
appuyant sur les poussoirs on a un
certain sentiment qui permet de lire
l'heure ça c'est incroyable en termes de
complications horlogères à l'heure
actuelle c'est vraiment ce qui se fait
de mieux c'est très très complexe on
peut avoir 800 900 pièces dans ce type
de mouvement qu'il faut tout assemblé à
la main régler c'est c'est fascinant on
va voir aussi tout ce qui va être les
tourillon donc le tourbillon c'est
pareil c'est quelque chose qui était
inventé par louis
avant abraham louis breguet pardon qui
avait constaté à l'époque que les
montres comportait donc dans les poches
les montres à gousset elle était tout le
temps à la verticale en fait il a
constaté que la gravité jouer sur le
balancier qu'on a vu tout à l'heure le
balancier spiral et donc qui ils
influencent elles à des riffs il s'est
dit tiens comment je vais pouvoir
compenser ça et il a imaginé une cage ou
là que cette cage qui fait tourner
pendant une minute et qui va compenser
la gravité puisqu'elle va tourner et
donc la gravité va tirer partout autour
du spiral et donc ça a permis justement
d'avoir des mouvements incroyable alors
on a gardé sa sur les montres
comme ça à bracelet ça a moins d'intérêt
puisque comme vous pouvez le voir ma
montre je la porte dans tous les sens
quand je bouge donc la gravité se fait
déjà partout mais on a gardé ce système
parce que déjà c'est beau et c'est
vraiment quelque chose de incroyable à
regarder et techniquement c'est
incroyable évidemment c'est très cher
mais c'est pas grave
alors il ya aussi d'autres catégories
dans l'ain dans les montres qui sont
intéressantes et notamment les montres
érotique
alors c'est c'est vraiment une catégorie
très particulier qui a été vu au tout
début donc en chine et en fait c'est
clairement c'était un petit peu notre
notre film du du premier samedi du mois
oui de l'époque en fait c'était vraiment
quelque chose de coquins c'était très
souvent cachés
derrière des montres très banal très
aseptisé en fait ils pouvaient elles
mettre des scènes un petit peu obscène
vraiment s'était débridée à l'époque un
jouet neuf il ya des choses assez
surprenante j'ai pas pu mettre tout ce
que tout ce qui se faisait mais c'était
vraiment intéressant et c'est resté
puisqu'on voit que blanc parfait des
séries comme ça qui fonctionne très bien
alors il ya de la gravure il ya aussi de
l'automate pour essayer d'avoir des
mouvements c'est vraiment particulier
c'est un domaine très intéressant dans
leur logis
alors on a aussi énormément de systèmes
différents c'est ça qui est intéressant
dans l'horlogerie c'est qu'on n'a pas
forcément toujours des innovations en
termes de technique des mouvements mais
on peut aussi avoir des innovations en
termes de lecture de l'heure par exemple
ici on a une demande pour les aveugles
donc comme vous pouvez le voir c'est
très simple à lire et c'est très
pratique est très intelligent on a aussi
consenti chez king qui fait des choses
assez coloré assez dingue notamment avec
les yeux pour lire l'heure et on ne
dirait pas comme ça mais c'est très
complexe de d'avoir les les aiguilles
enfin les aiguilles les la lecture de
l'heure comme ça des centres est
alors pour moi c'est de parler
d'horlogerie sans parler de la précision
chronométrique c'est à dire qu on a
essayé nous aussi d'être un petit peu
dans dance est dans ce débat c'est un
débat entre passionnés d'horlogerie qui
est qui n'en finit pas et pourtant qu'il
n'a aucun sens parce que à l'heure
actuelle et le montre à quartz à 15
euros et plus précise tu ne montres à
200000 euros mécanique mais bien donc ça
n'a pas de sens et pour autant c'est
quelque chose qui nous anime parce que
c'est techniquement compliqué à régler
et a énormément de paramètres à prendre
en compte et non nous avons fait donc
plusieurs montre que nous avons fait
passer à un institut français qui
s'appelle la vipère de besançon et qui
certifie nos montres comme étant précise
suivant leurs critères donc c'est très
compliqué on voit là plusieurs de nos
horloger qui sont en train de travailler
là-dessus pour régler tous les
paramètres et ensuite proposer les
montres qui vont passer 16 jours dans
les mains d r d
de cet institut la et à titre d'exemple
depuis les 15 dernières années il ya à
peu près une moins de 600 monde qui ont
réussi à avoir cette certification là
partout dans le monde on c'est vrai
qu'on me demande très souvent
qu'est-ce que
quel est l'avenir de l'horlogerie
traditionnelle
et c'est vrai que j'ai souvent cette
réflexion et moi j'ai pas besoin de
monde puisque de toute façon j'ai
scheller sur mon téléphone donc des
montres mécaniques ça n'a aucun intérêt
c'est pas faux en revanche c'est quand
même pas la même chose l'on cherche
vraiment ce côté artisanal
cette précision cette ce côté futiles et
inutiles au final de l'horlogerie et
c'est vrai que ça force à nous fatiguer
un petit plus à savoir répondre à ça
mais en dehors de ça aussi ça quand on
me demande très souvent est ce que
qu'est la montre que tu préfères quel
est ici tu devais choisir qu'une seule
monde qu'est ce que tu choisirais et
pour moi c'est impossible à répondre
puisque c'est comme si je vous demandais
si vous deviez porter qu'une seule
une seule paire de chaussures qu'est-ce
que vous mettriez c'est ça dépend
vraiment de si vous êtes dans le monde
du sport ou si vous êtes vous voulez
être habillé si vous êtes dans le monde
professionnel ça dépend comment donc
c'est impossible d'y répondre on n'a pas
vraiment de deux marques préférées donc
donc voila un petit peu j'espère que
j'ai un petit peu survolé le domaine de
l'horlogerie et que ça vous a plu
si vous avez des questions n'hésitez pas
j'essaierai d'y répondre voilà merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]